the russian accusations uh are absurd
they're laughable
and uh
you know in the words of my irish
catholic grandfather
a bunch of malarkey there's nothing to
it it's classic russian propaganda and
uh and uh i wouldn't uh if i were you i
wouldn't give it uh
i wouldn't give it a drop of ink worth
worth paying attention to yeah but can
you explain to us what has there been
any relationship between them we are not
not
developing biological or chemical
weapons inside ukraine it's not
happening they have a large biological
and chemical weapons program
so it's a pattern but they also have the
capacity uh well i'm not going to get
into specific intelligence we look at
all of those factors um and we also know
and one of the reasons one of the the
the main issue that prompted my twitter
thread yesterday was that russia has a
history also of inventing outright lies
like this which is the suggestion that
the united states has a chemical and
biological weapons program or ukraine
does that they're operating russia is
the one is the country that has a
chemical and biological weapons program
so uh
the objective uh was to uh make clear uh
the inaccuracy of the information the
misinformation they're trying to put out
and make clear to the world that they
not only have the capacity they have a
history of using chemical and biological
weapons and that in this moment we
should have our eyes open for that
possibility